Space travel takes a really long time.
And as much as I love board games and asking
my mom if we’re there yet, hanging out and
eating snacks may not be the best strategy
for killing time on our way to the red planet.
That’s mostly because being awake for that
long means we’re gonna need to eat and drink
and do all those normal human things – which
means bringing a LOT of supplies with us.
Not super practical.
But, if we’ve learned anything from movies,
the solution is to sleep our way through space.
But is long-term snoozing like Ripley in Alien even
possible?
To tackle this space-sleep conundrum, let’s
start with the basics, without the assistance
of sedatives or fancy chambers, we have to
know how long humans can sleep on our own.
Typically we only sleep about eight hours
per night, and though that can vary, it’s
unusual for healthy adults to regularly sleep
over 10 hours.
But, in the 1960s two volunteers put sleep
duration to the test.
They were monitored as they lived, isolated,
underground for several months.
In the absence of daylight, their sleep cycles
got real crazy.
One guy fell asleep for 30 hours, and woke
up thinking it was just a short nap!
30 hours!
In the following years researchers did more
organized, controlled studies, and found … when
isolated from light and other external markers
of time, it’s not that uncommon for us to
fall into longer sleep cycles.
All of this could be a great natural starting
point for hacking our sleep to fit our space-travel
needs, but it won’t get us all the way there;
since extended sleep periods are often followed
by extended waking periods.
So we’re gonna need something a little more
sophisticated than a dark room to get us into
deep space.
And luckily for future Mark Watney’s---
there are lots of scientists trying to figure
this out.
One of the most exciting projects is in the
works is at a company called SpaceWorks Enterprises,
yes that is the name of a real company that
actually exists.
They’ve been working with NASA to develop
a stasis chamber they say could keep astronauts
asleep for 2 weeks at a time, and possibly
longer.
Now, I know what you’re thinking, two weeks
won’t get me to Mars!
And, you're right, but SpaceWorks has a
plan for that -- they suggest stacking these
shorter hibernation periods back to back,
with a couple of days in between to walk around
and stretch out.
The crew can rotate waking and sleeping shifts,
and voila!
You’ll be in deep space before you know
it.
First, this design isn’t for an individual
sleep pod, but a shared sleeping chamber.
The chamber works by lowering a group of astronaut’s
body temperatures to 32 degrees celsius, then
it sedates them to suppress the body’s reactions
to the cold.
The low temp would put their bodies into a
mild hypothermia, slowing down your metabolic
rate and preventing injury from lack of oxygen.
Robotic arms will check up on the astronauts
while they slumber, and any bodily waste will
be -- well let’s just say there are catheters involved.
Sounds like hypersleep to ME!
Aside from greatly reducing the necessary
food and water for the mission, these stasis
chambers could also have some other major
benefits, like requiring a smaller area to
be thoroughly protected from radiation.
The researchers also want to equip the chambers
with artificial gravity, which could prevent
a lot of the negative health effects associated
with long term space travel.
But Danger, Will Robinson!
Don’t try taking one of these bad boys to
Proxima Centauri.
We still haven’t figured out how to slow
down aging, so even though you wouldn’t
have to be entertained and fed on the 81,000
year journey, you’d still be VERY dead by
the time you get there.
Sadly, these don’t exist yet, so if we send
astronauts to mars in the 2030s they might
just have to sleep like normal humans.
In the meantime, as a person who enjoys a
good cold nap, I hope they make an Earth version.
Figuring out how to sleep our way to Mars
is one thing, but what do we eat once we get
there?
NASA is working on that too, you can check
out our video about it, here.
And one last thing, doctors actually already
use mild hypothermic states like these to
prevent brain damage after cardiac arrest.
Saving lives and getting us to space at the
same time.
Man, science is cool.
Thanks for watching!